warning this video contains massive
spoilers for every season of game Game
of Thrones is famous or maybe infamous
for a high body count the show has
proven over the years but even fan
favorites aren't safe here's where some
of our favorite departed Game of Thrones
actors are now Ned Stark was the first
shocking death of so so many to come
since then actor Sean Bean has been in a
ton of movies like the Martian as well
as TV shows the Frankenstein Chronicles
and broken up next he's starring in the
movie drunk on Malibu Cabo is wrong
although he was only on for one season
Jason Momoa is Khal Drogo left a huge
impression and is still a fan fave today
he's starring in season 1 of the Netflix
show frontier and he nabbed the role of
Aquaman in the mega budget Justice
League Momoa is also a huge presence on
social media the red wedding was the
most shocking twist on Game of Thrones
up to that point it dispatched with
multiple beloved characters including
Robb Stark the king in the north
today actor Richard Madden is currently
starring in Medici maskers and Florence
on Netflix Catelyn Stark also bit the
big one in the red wig actor Michelle
Fairley is about to star as another
king's mother in the upcoming Starz
drama the white princess hopefully she
has better luck this time around
another major casualty of the red
wedding was Rob's pregnant wife - Lisa
Oona Chaplin who is actually the
granddaughter of film legend Charlie
Chaplin is currently starring alongside
Tom Hardy in the FX drama taboo Joffrey
Baratheon or should we say Lannister the
crown is mine the inbred King everyone
loved to hate met his grisly end at his
own wedding mere hours after marrying
Margaery Tyrell in season four
since then star Jack Gleeson who
publicly stated he didn't enjoy his
celebrity status stepped away from
acting for several years he returned to
the stage in 2016 with a theater group
he co-founded you know Newton you grit
and John everyone's favorite power
couple beyond the wall had their time
together cut short in season four Rose
Leslie has kept busy with a starring
role in the CBS show the good fight she
and co-star Kit Harington have also been
dating in real life ever since their
on-screen pairing don't leave me alone
in this world
whenever Pedro Pascal made a big
impression as the swarthy charming
oberyn martell
unfortunately he was dispatched by the
mountain after just one season
fortunately Pascal has found plenty of
work in shows like Netflix's narcos and
movies like The Great Wall co-starring
Matt Damon easily the most upsetting
death since pregnant ELISA sweet
innocent Shireen Baratheon met her
demise at the hands of the red woman in
season 5 actor Carrie Ingram gave a
trilling performance and will get to see
more of her in the upcoming Netflix
series free reign later in 2017 poor
poor fan favorite Hodor gave his life
too well
hold the door actor Christian Arne is
actually an accomplished DJ who tours
regularly
he is currently touring with a show
called appropriately rave of Thrones
despite her craftiness and cunning
Margaery Tyrell couldn't outwit Cersei
Lannister
and she met her demise at the end of
season 6 Natalie Dormer recently voiced
the character in the video game Mass
Effect Andromeda there are also rumors
that she could be the very first female
Doctor Who the dime the service of the
gods would please each and every one
Jonathon prices high Sparrow was a
beautifully understated villain Price is
a veteran actor who's been in dozens of
classic films over the years he's
currently starring alongside Oona
Chaplin in FX's taboo we've just
scratched the surface of beloved Game of
Thrones characters who are no longer
with us
who do you miss are you curious with
Thomas brodie-sangster II when rayon or
Charles dance are up to today let us
know in the comments below and don't
forget to subscribe